the human immune system is the most
complex biological system we know after
the human brain and yet most of us never
learn how it works or what it is
your immune system consists of hundreds
of tiny and two large organs it has its
own transport network spread throughout
your body every day it makes hundreds of
billions of fresh cells organized like
an army with soldiers captains
intelligence officers heavy weapons and
crazy suicide bombers
it's not some sort of abstract entity
your immune system is you
your biology protecting you from the
billions of microorganisms that want to
consume you and from your own perverted
cells that turn into cancer
it's so manifold that it's impossible to
cover in one video so we'll make a
series looking at different aspects of
it
today what happens when your body is
invaded and your first lines of defenses
are engaged in a fight for life and
death
[Music]
it's been a normal day when suddenly the
world explodes and an asteroid rips the
sky open
countless alien life forms invade ready
to destroy cities and infrastructure and
eat civilians or this is what your cells
experience
you look at your bleeding thumb that you
just cut on a dirty twig in the park
how annoying
but inside the wound a horrible
catastrophe has happened
there are dead cells and blood and dirt
everywhere
even worse countless bacteria invade the
warm caverns between your helpless cells
to explore their new home steal your
resources and poop everywhere
immediately the first stage of your
defense kicks in
the cells that survived the impact or
are hurt or dying scream in panic
releasing an onslaught of chemical alarm
signals that awaken your immune system
the first cells to show up are
macrophages
if an average cell with the size of a
human a macrophage would be the size of
a black rhino a stoic cell in principle
but you wouldn't want to annoy it
bacteria do annoy them
within seconds the large cells attack
and begin killing them without mercy
they stretch out parts like the arms of
an octopus and grab the bacteria to
swallow them whole and digest them alive
a macrophage can eat 100 bacteria before
it's exhausted
but there are too many enemies so the
macrophages call for reinforcements
in your blood hundreds of thousands of
neutrophils pick up their signals and
move to the battlefield
neutrophils are intense suicide warriors
that only live to kill
they're so enthusiastic about killing
that they kill themselves a few days
after birth so they don't have time to
accidentally destroy your body from the
inside
as soon as neutrophils arrive they begin
vomiting deadly chemicals of bacteria or
devour them
they are so careless in their attacks
that they are causing real damage to
your own cells but collateral damage is
not their concern now
or ever
some neutrophils go so far to push their
suicide button and explode casting wide
and toxic nets made from their own dna
filled with deadly chemicals that trap
and kill bacteria
sometimes they can continue fighting
after that even though they're sort of
dead already this is how much fun they
have killing
while the battle rages your blood
vessels let fluid stream into the
battlefield like a dam opening up
towards a valley
you notice this as inflammation your
thumb swells up a little and gets red
and warm
the fluid brings a silent killer into
the battle zone millions of complement
proteins a sort of automated liquid
weapon that stuns and kills bacteria by
ripping holes into them we made a whole
video explaining them in detail
we're reaching a crossroad now if things
go well your first line of defense kills
the invaders quickly but sometimes the
enemies are too strong and would
overwhelm your defenses eventually which
means certain death for you the human
this is the hour of the dendritic cell
your immune system's intelligence
officer while your soldiers were bashing
in heads it was collecting samples by
ripping bacteria into tiny parts and
covering itself in it
like a soldier decorating itself in the
guts of a dead enemy
the cell leaves the battlefield and
enters the superhighway of your immune
system that connects all your tissues
with your immune headquarters your lymph
nodes
the dendritic cell coming from the
battlefield is looking for a helper t
cell which is a sort of all-purpose
commander cell within your immune army
but not any helper t cell one that
happens to have just the right weapon
for the bacteria that infected your
wound
so it goes around and rubs itself still
covered in bacteria parts against every
helper t-cell it meets
most t-cells are a bit disgusted and not
interested but after a few hours
something clicks
a helper t cell recognizes the bacteria
parts
this cell is the weapon that's needed
right now
the dendritic cell is overjoyed and
activates the helper t cell okay wait
how come your immune system has a cell
that has a weapon against the specific
bacteria that infected you
well your immune system has a perfect
weapon against every possible disease in
the universe against the black death the
coronavirus or an infection that will
emerge in 100 years on mars
we'll talk about this a bit more in the
next video because it's very complex so
for now just know that you have billions
of unique helper t-cells that each have
weapons against every possible enemy
after the right t-cell is activated your
second line of defense awakes and rises
like a teenager that needs to get up on
a school day very slowly your heavy
weapons are incredibly effective but
they're not fast
the activated helper t cell begins to
clone itself over and over again
one becomes two two become four until
there are thousands of them now they
split into two groups
the first group quickly moves to help
out your soldiers
at the battlefield things are getting
out of hand
a tired macrophage is ready to give up
after fighting for days it just wants to
go to sleep like many of its buddies
have done already
but now the helper t cells arrive one of
them comes to the tired macrophage and
whispers something using special
chemical signals
in a heartbeat the demoralized soldier
feels fresh again
but there's something else a hot white
anger the macrophage knows what it needs
to do
kill
invigorated it throws itself against the
enemies once again
all over the battlefield this begins to
happen
meanwhile the second group of helper t
cells was working on activating another
line of defense b cells your antibody
factories antibodies are protein super
weapons that look like tiny crabs with
two pincers to grab enemies
just like the helper t cells there are b
cells in your body that are able to make
just the right antibodies for every
possible enemy
and the helper t cell is looking for
exactly these b cells
after a day or two the right b cell is
found and begins to clone itself
as soon as enough clones have been made
each b-cell begins pumping out up to 2
000 antibodies per second about a week
after you injured yourself and bacteria
invaded your second line of defense
finally arrives in full force
the tiny army begins to saturate the
battlefield pinching and stunning
desperate bacteria
the antibodies clump them together and
make them unable to move or fight while
your soldiers massacre the defenseless
victims
the tide is turning fast
as the last enemies are cleaned up your
soldiers realize they are no longer
needed and begin to kill themselves to
save resources
but not all of them a few helper t cells
remain and turn into memory cells
they will guard the tissue for years
making sure the same bacteria will never
again gain a foothold here
similarly a few b-cells will stay alive
and keep producing a low amount of
antibodies making you immune against
this bacteria maybe for the rest of your
life
one day you wake up and notice that the
wound has grown over and left nothing
but a faint red mark
you were completely unaware of the drama
yourselves had to deal with
for you the whole ordeal was a slight
annoyance while for millions of cells it
was a desperate fight for life and death
but this is just the beginning of the
epic story that unfolds inside you every
day and is told in full in immune a
journey into the mysterious system that
keeps you alive written by philip detmer
the founder and head writer of kotzkozak
the book is a beautifully illustrated
deep dive into the immune system the
most important thing you don't know
enough about that will forever change
how you think about your body
written to be as simple and fun as
possible it's been an ongoing passion
project for almost a decade because the
immune system is just about the most
amazing and fascinating topic there is
so go on a journey and get to know your
own body from mystery organs murder
universities to the largest library in
the universe
explore how incredibly vast your immune
system is and how it actually works how
it fights enemies from cancer to hiv or
just the flu
learn how you can boost it and if that's
actually a good idea
the book will be out in six weeks and it
would mean the world to us and philip if
you could pre-order it pre-ordering is
super important in the world of books
and in contrast to games we can
guarantee that it's actually finished
and there will be no day one patch
there's a link in the description
this is the end of a decade-long
personal journey and we'd love to see
what you think
thank you for watching
[Music]
you